de la douceur brestoise la dureté de
l'hiver russe l'artiste versailles et
vincent vallat houle attire la lumière
des couleurs d intensité qui dirige son
pinceau je voyage pour pas par ce à dire
qu'on par exemple il ya quelques jours
je regarde la météo et neige et ivan
langer haye va neiger en fleurs je vais
j'y vais deux géants fleurs donc on met
tout de suite dans la voiture le cheval
et des toiles et je file à en fleurs
là-dessus la météo avait changé il
pleuvait la neige avait fondu pas mais
c'est pas grave puisque et lexie quand
c'est l'idée de départ s'il n'a pas
abandonné la peinture à l'huile vincent
préfère aujourd'hui oublier la technique
l'émotion et les sensations font le
reste
comme disait monnaie j'ai voulu peindre
un paysage suis revenu j'avais j'avais
fait le paysage avait pas fait un
tableau et des failles euros vinci pour
faire un tableau 40 ans de travail de
peinture de pérégrinations qui ont donné
envie à l'artiste de faire le point
penser de manière thématique cette
exposition est pour vincent l'occasion
de faire une rétrospective
je me retrouve au milieu de tous ces
tableaux maintenant un petit peu comme
on on regarde le fil de sa vie et je me
dis qu'à sa stèle anecdote qui me
revient tel souvenir de ce tableau de
souvenirs de ce pays et je m'aperçois
que finalement il me reste tellement à
découvrir encore après dix-huit mois de
pause vincent présent près de 70 toiles
qui donne envie de voyager à notre tour
[Musique]